le giro un secret de fabrication bien
gardé depuis 1912 dans ses cuves du
sirop de sucre chauffée à 94 degrés
avant d'être travaillée on peut voir ici
que les opérateurs préparent tout ce qui
est colorants arômes et petits
ingrédients une recette que découvre
marc-antoine pour ce sertisseur de
diamant à genève
cette visite est l'occasion d'en
apprendre plus sur cette élection qu'il
consomme depuis son enfance
maintenant j'ai 30 ans mais monnaye
arias il ya vingt ans c'était pas un
grand comme ça il y avait juste la
petite entreprise au centre ville de
bourges et de voir ce que c'est ce que
c'est devenu c'est quand même grands
comme lui ils sont près de 15000
visiteurs attendus pour observer toutes
les étapes d'un processus millimétré et
surprenant ils sont reçus repris des
méthodes de fabrication
ils pensent pas à trouver forcément des
machines automatiques aussi perfectionné
et puis la qualité de nos contrôles qui
est très importante
on a environ par produits une centaine
de contrôles ici un carton de 6
bouteilles sortent toutes les secondes
de la chaîne de fabrication 25 millions
de bouteilles par an un entrepôt de
16000 palette plein à craquer et qui
nécessite une extension avec 25 millions
d'euros d'investissements et une
croissance à deux chiffres la marque
berrichonne a trouvé la clé pour couper
rire 150 pays la clé c'est vraiment de
s'adapter au profil et les goûts locaux
donc pour ça on a des experts boisson
qui sont présents dans le monde entier
et qui vont identifier les profils et
les goûts spécifiques de chaque pays
donc par exemple en allemagne la fleur
de sureau qui a un profil très local en
chine on a le pen dan qui a aussi un
goût très spécifique que proche du
palais des chinois voilà donc c'est
autant de spécificités qui font qu'on
arrive à pénétrer chacun des marchés
prochaine étape le botswana et le
zimbabwe pour exporter des quelques 150
parfum créé par le sirop tier berrichon